[Music]
jay is in battle creek michigan hi jay
how are you
hey how you guys doing better than i
deserve how can we help
hey dave so um real quick i just want to
say that my wife and i found you uh
during our when our parish priest was
giving us wedding counseling uh he set
us up with a total money makeover and
since then we have paid off 30 000 in
debt
built up a fully funded emergency fund
and we bought a house with twenty
percent down
eight thousand under after using an elp
i wanna start off by saying that so
thank you wow thank you brother you game
on
how can we help today
now my question is with the new house my
mother-in-law wants to buy us a lot of
gifts for christmas see between
my wife and i know that that she has no
control over her finances she has
multiple credit cards a car loan and she
doesn't even have her own place we love
her we love her so much but we just
don't know how we can tell her no to the
gifts that she's expecting to buy
um i've even offered to give her i i
told my wife i offered i can give her uh
this little money makeover set her up
with ramsey plus with financial peace
but i just don't how do we tell her no
to the gift i i just feel bad doing that
to her since we just got our debt
how long have you been married
uh we've been there now for just over a
year
is your mother-in-law single
yes she is living with her mom so my
wife's grandma
okay
all right
here's the
a i want to applaud your spirit and
applaud you you've had some a string of
some pretty remarkable success
financially
and man
like anybody whose life has been changed
by something positive you want to run
out on the street and
tell everybody and especially those that
you love
the hard reality that you're you're
you're picking up now is you can't
control what she does
and it's there's few things in life
harder than watching people you love
make decisions that are going to hurt
them
if you wanted to you could set up a
boundary and say hey this year we don't
want gifts we want to do this but
dave i mean you're a grandparent i'm not
that that may be more harmful let me
say a communicate a different message to
her than you intend to
um you can give her that gift
uh the total money makeover something
like that
but the idea that a young guy who's
marrying her daughter who's just come
into her life a year ago is gonna give
her this
is gonna come be her savior man i want
to relieve you of that brother that's
not your job your job is to love her the
best you can and by the way you're not
gonna be very good at that job yeah
or is they love her the best you can no
i'm the job of fixing her life yeah you
can't do that yeah love her daughter
well how about that yeah so
second thing is this
uh
how's the relationship between your
daughter and her mom
your wife and her mom very good
okay
then you don't need to say a boo
you don't need to say a single syllable
not your mother she needs to talk to her
mom
and it would at
most
at most nothing is okay saying nothing's
okay but saying at most hey mom
we're really enjoying debt free
and we've worked really hard to get out
of that and i know you're struggling and
and i appreciate your generous spirit so
much
you're such an amazing mom
uh but i gotta tell you it makes us feel
very very weird that you're borrowing
money to give us gifts when we've worked
so hard to get out of debt
and and we wish you would dial it back
and not borrow any money to bless us
uh but you can do what you want to do
and we're going to love you either way
but it just makes us feel weird and i
just wanted you to know that
because i i i it's it's it takes a
little of the joy off of it because we
know it's not bringing because it's
bringing harm to you
and that's a that's a mother-daughter
conversation that's not one-year
son-in-law coming in and being like oh
yeah hey lady you know you don't get
what we're saying you're not even in the
room when this happens
and it's not by text and it's not by
phone it's in person if at all possible
absolutely and it's one time and then
drop it
and move on i love your heart but
yeah you cannot fix her
she's not within your control yeah and
it's again it's it's one of the things
john and i say around here all the time
one of the most painful parts of
adulthood is watching people we love do
stupid things yeah so we can't keep them
from doing it yeah whether it's super
destructive things
like addictions or uh abuse or whatever
all the way to
uh you know simply buying christmas
gifts on a credit card that you wish you
didn't do and i know the irony of this
is that this is an advice show and
that's what advice pays my bills
but in the real world in relationships
and people's you know we're going to go
to christmas parties this year we're
going to hang out with their in-laws
this year
man i've just i've burned people over
the course of my life trying to throw
advice into situations that where it
wasn't asked and so i want to be invited
in anymore that's it i have a rule
i do not give my opinion
until you ask me yes invite me in and if
you ask me i'm obligated going full dave
you asked that's right that's really
true on the show i mean you guys call
them
so we're going to tell you yeah you know
but i don't drive up beside some guy at
the stoplight and go hey looks like you
got a lot of payments
stupid car killer
idiot yeah [ __ ]
exactly
so i yeah i have thought that people of
course you have of course
and you say it you just have your
windows up but
the the the number of times i have gone
to someone said well hey you know uh
wow yeah the only time i'm gonna
intersect the only time i'm gonna
intersect into someone's life uninvited
is if i think they're in danger that's
exactly right or a child's entanglement
yep and then i'll put most of you in
jail in that case yes so um yeah you
don't want me around in that situation
yeah that's exactly right if someone's
gonna hurt themselves yeah i will call
if you start talking to me about suicide
9-1-1 yep yeah i don't play with this i
am not playing with this but other than
that i'm gonna wait to be invited in and
so here's a great thing jay this last
caller if he lives his life of
she's gonna want to know she's gonna
want to know yeah maybe maybe but i'll
be honest
hardly any of our relatives do our stuff
okay
it's just full disclosure that's right
all right a couple of them do but most
of them just think wow they did kind of
good over there at the ramsey look
that's like what exactly yeah oh well
that's the way it is you know so uh yeah
well
we know you don't like credit cards but
yeah